[Music]
hey Megan I thought that I have been
clear about the number of buttons that
can be unbuttoned are you body shaming
her right now
Jeremy come on it's winter can we put
dancer and prancer back and their stable
if I give you like your stripper
girlfriend put my children on her
motorcycle one more time I will gone
girl you so hard I'm just going okay so
are you gonna be inviting your fake
girlfriend to the holiday party later I
mean there's one make sure you have time
to inflator this party has to rock did
you rent a live baby what it's cheaper
than you think
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Savannah oh my gosh you guys are gonna
have so much fun tonight
I'm not even gonna County cuz we're
friends right yeah we're not you do not
want to die at the hands of Lululemon
here be real embarrassing for you you're
a large guy and she's made a nothing but
salad and SmartWater it's my birthday
oh really committing it's nice like the
candles Merry Christmas Brigid
break down the chimney folks